THE COMPLAINTS AND WHY I'M
VOTING AGAINST KEVIN McCARTHY
BUT I WOULDN'T -- LIKE JIM
JORDAN ISN'T GOING TO CHANGE.
>> LET'S BRING IN SOMEBODY WHO
KNOWS THESE CROWDS ALL OF THESE
CROWDS VERY WELL.
THE FORMER ACTING CHIEF OF STAFF
FOR FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP AND A
FORMER REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN
FROM SOUTH CAROLINA WHO IS A
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE FREEDOM
CAUCUS.
MR. MULVANEY GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THIS FIGHT GOES BACK TO WHEN YOU
WERE FIRST ELECTED TO THE HOUSE
AND THE TEA PARTY WAVE IN 2010
AND YOU WERE A LEADER OF THE
CAUCUS AND RAN IN 2013, 2015 YOU
VOTED FOR BOEHNER AS SPEAKER AND
YOU HAD RESERVATIONS.
TELL US HOW YOU SEE THIS PLAYING
OUT.
>> YEAH, I DON'T THINK I RAN FOR
SPEAKER IN 2013 BUT ALL THE REST
OF THAT IS RIGHT.
>> OKAY.
>> I DIDN'T VOTE FOR BOEHNER.
>> YOUR NAME WAS FLOATED I
SHOULD SAY.
>> THAT'S VERY FLATTERING.
HOW DOES IT SHAKE OUT?
HONESTLY, IF IT'S NOT KEVIN I
DON'T KNOW WHO IT IS.
THAT'S THE CONVERSATION I'VE
BEEN HAVING WITH THE 19 NEVER
KEVIN FOLKS, MANY OF WHOM ARE MY
FRIENDS.
GUYS, WHAT IS THE PLAN HERE?
IF NOT HIM, WHO?
JIM JORDAN CAN'T GET ELECTED
SPEAKER.
ANY GROUP OF FIVE OR SIX VETO P.
IT HAS TO BE UNANIMOUS.
JIM JORDAN AND I WORK TOGETHER
SIX YEARS AND START THE FREEDOM
CAUCUS TOGETHER, I'M A HUGE JIM
JORDAN FAN BUT THERE IS NOT FIVE
OR SIX MODERATE REPUBLICANS THAT
WOULDN'T ACCEPT JIM JORDAN AS
SPEAKER AND MORE IMPORTANTLY,
EMPOWER THE RIGHT WING OF THE
PARTY AND REWARD THEM FOR THIS
BEHAVIOR, NO, I DON'T SEE THAT
HAPPENING.
IT'S EITHER KEVIN OR SOMEBODY
THAT WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT WHO IS
MORE INTO THE CENTER OF MY PARTY
OR A COMPROMISED PERSON WHO IS A
DEMOCRAT.
I DON'T SEE HOW THE FOLKS WHO
ARE MAGA REPUBLICANS, THE
MAJORITY VOTED FOR KEVIN
McCARTHY TODAY.
THE MAJORITY OF THE CAUCUS, IT'S
NOT FREEDOM BUT A GROUP OF
PEOPLE WHO HAPPEN TO BE IN THE
FREEDOM CAUCUS AND I DON'T SEE
HOW ANYBODY THEY WOULD FIND
ACCEPTABLE HAS THE VOTES TO GET
SPEAKER.
IT'S KEVIN OR NOBODY.
>> SO YOU HEARD CONGRESSMAN CHIP
ROY OR MAYBE DIDN'T HEAR CHIP
ROY BUT HEARD HIM OVER THE LAST
FEW DAYS AND WEEKS TALKING ABOUT
WHAT HE WANTS AND A MORE OPEN
AMENDMENT PROCESS.
I CAN'T NECESSARILY DISCERN WHAT
THE OTHER 18 WANT.
CONGRESSMAN BIRON DONALDS JUST
WANTS THIS TO BE OVER OBVIOUSLY
BUT IN TERMS OF THE OTHER 18, IS
THERE AN AGENDA THERE THAT YOU
CAN TELL, OTHER THAN THEY DON'T
LIKE KEVIN McCARTHY AND THEY
LIKE TO SHAKE THINGS UP?
>> I THINK THAT'S IT.
I THINK THEY REALLY JUST DON'T
LIKE KEVIN AND THEY LIKE THE
ATTENTION.
THEY LIKE THE CHAOS.
THEY'RE ON TV MORE IN THE LAST
48 HOURS THAN THEIR ENTIRE
CAREERS.
I LISTENED TO CHIP AND LIKE CHIP
AND RESPECT CHIP BUT MUCH WHAT
HE'S ASKED FOR KEVIN OFFERED.
A LOT OF THINGS HE'S COMPLAINING
ABOUT, FOR EXAMPLE THE $1.7
TRILLION WAS HANDLED BY NANCY
PELOSI AND A LOT OF THINGS KEVIN
ISN'T IN POSITION TO GIVE.
THEY WANT SPECIFIC PEOPLE ON
COMMITTEES.
THAT'S NOT HOW THE REPUBLICAN
COMMITTEE WORKS.
THE MEMBERS VOTE ON WHO GOES ON
THE COMMITTEES AND THEY'RE
ASKING KEVIN TO GIVE THEM
SOMETHING HE CAN'T GIVE THEM.
I THINK -- I WASN'T IN THE
MEETING TODAY DURING THE HOUSE
REPUBLICAN CONGRESS MEETING
BEFORE THE VOTE BUT I UNDERSTAND
THAT KEVIN GOT UP AND SAID WHAT
MORE DO YOU WANT AND THE ANSWER
WAS ESESSENTIALLY, WE DON'T WAN
YOU.
IT'S NOT ABOUT POLICY OR
PRACTICE.
WHEN WE VOTED AGAINST JOHN
BOEHNER, WE DID IT BECAUSE HE
WAS TRYING TO MARGINALIZE THE
CONSERVATIVES.
McCARTHY WANTS TO MAKE JIM
JORDAN ON THE COMMITTEE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S PRACTICAL.
I DON'T THINK IT'S POLICY.
I JUST THINK IT'S A COMBINATION
OF THEY DON'T LIKE KEVIN AND
THEY LIKE THE ATTENTION AND
THAT'S A REALLY, REALLY BAD WAY
TO RUN A SPEAKER RACE.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU DON'T
THINK BAD BEHAVIOR SHOULD BE
REWARDED BUT WE ARE NOW IN A
PLACE AS A COUNTRY THAT WE HAVE
NOT BEEN IN SINCE 1923 WITH
SOMEBODY RUNNING FOR SPEAKER AND
NOT WINNING ON THE FIRST BALLOT,
SECOND BALLOT, THIRD BALLOT, WHO
KNOWS HOW LONG THIS WILL GO.
AT WHAT POINT DO YOU START
THINKING I DON'T KNOW THAT KEVIN
McCARTHY CAN WIN AND EVEN IF HE
CAN, I DON'T KNOW HE CAN BE THE
SPEAKER EFFECTIVELY GIVEN THE
FACT THAT HE CAN'T EVEN GET THIS
DONE.
>> NO, I THINK THAT'S A FAIR
POINT.
I THINK THAT'S ONE LIKELY
OUTCOME.
IT'S EITHERSOMEBODY
LESS ACCEPTABLE TO ME.
I'LL USE A NAME.
IT'S A GUY I LIKE.
LET'S SAY FRED UPTON IS THIS
COMPROMISED CANDIDATE A LARGE
GROUP OF MODERATE REPUBLICANS
COME TOGETHER WITH DEMOCRATS AND
SAY KEVIN DOESN'T HAVE THE
VOTES.
THEY CAN'T ELECT ANYBODY BECAUSE
THEY WON'T TAKE ANYBODY TO THE
RIGHT OF KEVIN AND JIM JORDAN
DOESN'T HAVE THE VOTES AND RUN
DOWN GOOD CONSERVATIVES, THEY
DON'T HAVE THE VOTES.
WE NEED A SPEAKER.
WILL YOU VOTE WITH US WITH FRED
UPTON?
THAT'S GOT TO BE AN UNDESIRABLE
OUTCOME AND FRED WOULDN'T MIND
ME SAYING THAT.
THERE IS A WAY BAD BEHAVIOR
WOULDN'T BE REWARDED BUT
PUNISHED AND THAT'S WHAT I'M
AFRAID IS ONE OF THE OUTCOMES
THAT MIGHT HAPPEN UNDER THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
>> HERE IS ANOTHER QUESTION FOR
YOU, DONALD TRUMP AND HIS TEAM
ARE CLEARLY BEHIND KEVIN
McCARTHY.
IT TOOK THEM A LITTLE WHILE TO
GET THERE BUT THEY'RE THERE.
DONALD TRUMP ALSO WELDS
INCREDIBLE INFLUENCE WITH THESE
19 OR 20 REBELS.
IN SOME CASES HE CREATED THEM
AND RESPONSIBLE FOR THEM.
WHERE IS HE?
WHERE IS DONALD TRUMP?
BECAUSE THIS OBVIOUSLY IS
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S BAD FOR THE
COUNTRY, IT'S DEFINITELY BAD FOR
HOUSE REPUBLICANS.
>> YEAH, LOOK, WHERE IS HE?
WHO KNOWS.
WHERE HE PERCEIVED AS BEING
BECAUSE IN THIS BUSINESS
PERCEPTION IS OFTEN REALITY.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE'S ON THE
PHONE CALLING DAN BISHOP.
HE GOT DAN BISHOP ELECTED.
HE WAS A NEVER KEVIN PERSON.
IT'S PERCEIVED DONALD TRUMP IS
FOR KEVIN McCARTHY BECAUSE HE'S
BEEN WITH HIM UNTIL THIS POINT
AND I HAVE NO REASON TO THINK
HE'S AGAINST HIM RIGHT NOW.
IF KEVIN McCARTHY LOSES, IT'S A
MARK AGAINST DONALD TRUMP,
ANOTHER MARK AGAINST DONALD
TRUMP.
HE'LL BE RECEIVED AS BEING
WEAKER THAN THE MIDTERMS SO THE
OTHER PERSON WHO STANDS TO LOSE
HERE BECAUSE HE IS INVESTED IN
KEVIN IS DONALD TRUMP.
I GOT TO THINK THAT TRUMP KNOWS
THAT.
AND HE'S GOING TO BE WORKING
BEHIND THE SCENES.
I DON'T HAVE INFORMATION ONE WAY
OR THE OTHER BUT IF MCELDERRY
McCARTHY LOSES, ANOTHER LOSER
WOULD BE DONALD TRUMP.
>> HE'S CRITICAL OF THE